every step in the halcyon colony can
mean certain death that's why the game
gives you loads of weapons Armour and
modifications to suit your needs but can
you beat the outer worlds without
killing anyone and there are gonna be a
couple rules for this rule one is no
killing very obvious rule two is that
companions are allowed but they can also
not kill anyone either and rule 3 is
that I can choose any ending of my
choice I wasn't going to choose the
third option where you can shoot the
hope right into the Sun I feel like
that's a cop-out method so so I'm only
allowed to choose one of the two main
endings which is Phineas or the board
like every normal playthrough you must
pick your skills and attributes I went
for the max in perception section being
temperament and charm while a little bit
of dabbling in the mine section I also
decreased a little bit in the body
because I really didn't need weapons so
there was no point in having them and it
gave me extra points my attributes went
right to dialogue and the sneaked
reasons I knew I would definitely be
involved I also named and created my
character called Desmond das the medic
from Hacksaw Ridge since the medic
refused to kill anyone in the war I
thought it would fit well with this
video it's not perfect but seeing as the
game is only in first-person I wasn't
really too big of a deal already you
would assume that we hit our first major
roadblock in the sense that we ended up
killing Hawthorn but technically since
it wasn't on any of our consent and it
was Phineas we won't talk about it the
very beginning of the game is the same
just like every other playthrough you
run through the grass you break your
legs we talk to the spaceships choice
card and then you fight your first
enemies but since this is a no-kill run
we ignore all bharata's and run to the
ship after the usual talk with Ada we
leave and head back to Edgewater the
plan was to do quest the level of my
speech skill as well as level up my
inspiration and determination tree for
later Silas had asked for graveyard fees
and this is one of the many quests I
know you can complete without killing
anyone at so I seize the opportunity
after that I headed to Reed to start the
beginning of the main quests talking to
Reed he wanted me to divert the power to
Edgewater he also wanted Provo to come
with me but seeing as I didn't want
Parvati killing people I declined and
then DUP picking up her later we then
stopped at the botanical lab to talk to
Adelaide and then I actually ended up
talking to Thomas to get his quests as
well for the engineering book since it's
easy XP I would have done Grace's quest
but that allows me to actually kill
people to saves oh and I can't kill
people after
collecting the books for Thomas I
decided to start the quest for the main
story and this is where I forgot how
hard this might actually be see you
can't use terminals in this game when in
combat so why they're killing them or
having them not see you is your only
option multiple times this would require
me to leave a building and then come
back to reset the aggro levels of the
robots or enemies but it really wasn't
that big of a deal
eventually we snuck past the robots flip
the switches and diverted the power to
Edgewater afterwards I ended up picking
up Parvati and vicar max as companions I
planned on using the ID cartridge later
in the endgame to sneak through Tartarus
and I would end up using speech checks
against Phineas or Sofia I still hadn't
decided on whose ending I would do at
this moment
then then I would help by boosting my
companions skills that's when I figured
out you could change your companions to
passive mode and they won't attack
unless you tell them to I'm unsure if
this was common knowledge by a larger
group of people but this was the first
time me ever seeing this so this was a
huge change for the run as you can see
your companions also have skills each
one is assigned about three different
skills that they specialize in Parvati
of course being engineering for one of
her skills and they take a small portion
of the number that they have for their
skill and add it to yours so the plan
was to grab two companions who would
help me with speech and those best two
options were Sam and Felix all I needed
was 60 levels and inspiration to
increase the skill by a hundred percent
meaning I get even more points into the
skill without even using my own points
which is super useful because we're
trying to use as much as we're trying to
get as much XP as we can and seeing as
we can't kill enemies we're losing a
large amount of that with Edgewater
finished up in no time it was on to the
ground breaker Felix is stationed at
ground breakers all you got to do is
talk to him and then just talk to him
again when you come back easy as that we
did vicar max a side quest here as well
I had I didn't actually have plans of
even fully finishing this I didn't even
have plans of using him as I stated
before but I want to be extra xp for the
lock-picking and completing the small
quest cuz like I said I need all the XP
I can get here is this French I can't
[ __ ] read French the main goal for
groundbreaker was to shop at vendors
since I don't need a weapons or weapon
mods this would mean easy bits for me
and more money to go to my armor all I
needed was armor and then the armor that
I was actually grabbing was fully based
on the skill and not the actual armor
rating here we also did the beginning of
Ellie's quest once again for the XP and
talked to him to release her I needed
his seal cuz he and I needed
kbits for that because I've done this
multiple times where if you give Odom
the seal you can use that as leverage to
getting out Ellie's friend because you
had bought him the seal so it's kind of
like a I give I receive type thing we
headed to Rose Way for some easy money
in XP and if you know anything about
Rose way you know that the main type of
quests there are from three scientists
who need assistance Vaughn Orson and
crane we handle cranes first and this
was definitely one of the toughest ones
they're creatures and guards were tough
to sneak by it but before we got to the
research area we made a pit stop and got
the experiment finished that up and then
talked to Cassandra which I usually just
kill on sight but seeing as we can't
kill people I had to handle stuff a
different way Cassandra wanted a way out
before the antique lio guards killed her
so we had to cover up either the side or
the front entrance I needed of actually
doing both by mistake but it doesn't
really matter
I still can't for the life of me figure
out why these two specific outlaws won't
attack me but the other ones on the
opposite side of this building will it
doesn't make any sense to me at all but
passing those guys we meet Porter and
Auntie Cleo guard and convinced him that
everyone should leave he's apprising Lee
agreed and left after a couple speech
checks you ever had a good thing a place
it felt like you were supposed to be all
we had to do was sneak past the two
guards and get to Cassandra but for some
odd reason I couldn't still talk to her
even after opening up the door my guess
is that it was the two combat robots
that we had actually passed on the way
from Porter so instead I basically went
out the front entrance with the antique
lio guards and went back to the side
entrance for the sewer ladder is and
completely skipped that part walked past
the two guards and then finally made it
to Cassandra without learning anybody
and she was saved she did tell me in the
beginning that she was going to give
cranes notes to me but then she of
course lied so I could get her out I
would have blasted her right then and
there but rules are rules
so threw in some intimidation she ended
up giving him up the other two quest for
the other two scientists were pretty
easy either there was barely enemies at
all and it was a easy cash grab or there
was a few decent enemies but sneaking
around them was easy enough to get what
I needed we also ended up picking up the
acid stepper on the way out for Sam
since that's how we activate him so I
could get him as a companion and the
original plan was to give all the info
to gladdie get the money for the seal
and then go to Byzantium but ended up
realizing that giving back the stuff to
the scientists actually yields you the
same amount of money and but way more XP
that no account food Porter and his crew
are even
imagine I don't know what everyone's so
grimy about perry the platypus Amaya
having a grand old time playing go fish
with hot sauce packets so I ended up
buying the seal so I could release
Ellie's friend and the sad part was that
I actually never ended up going to
Byzantium through this question that
eight thousand bits was actually kind of
a waste but we got a little bit of XP
from Elly's quest regardless we finished
rows away pretty quickly about an hour
into my recording and we were on our way
to monarch I didn't feel like doing the
8,000 bit method and then going to the
board and I also didn't feel like paying
10,000 just to go to monarch so I told
Aida to just fly us right into the
danger zone obviously it's a bit farther
away than just going to stellar Bay but
I didn't mind running through a couple
manta Queen so it wasn't a big deal we
ended up making it to stellar Bay in no
time and we met Nyoka I already knew how
to get to Devil's Peak and I wanted to
keep salmon Felix since if she had to
come along I had to get rid of one of
them because I wanted to keep their
speech skills so I ended up declining
her advice and left her at the bar now
Devil's Peak is where this run ended up
taking a turn we ran through the front
entrance guards and made it inside no
problem this was some of the hardest
sneaking I had ever done in this game I
made multiple saves and restarted many
times so I wasn't caught the first one
wasn't too hard it was the next two
rooms after the elevator that followed
the middle room was an absolute [ __ ]
this specific guy kept seeing me and
after so many attempts I was actually
getting really good at reloading saves
constantly because of all pissed I was
getting but eventually I finally managed
to make it past this part with the two
guards by doing some time dilation past
him I'm not actually sure if this is
what caused it to work but I'll take it
anyway the room afterwards at the top
was very simple there was only two
guards but no matter what I tried haraam
would not open this door I tried seeing
if I would have only killing those two
guys would trigger something even though
it's against the rules I was just
brainstorming that didn't work I also
tried to see if I could sneak up behind
the ringleader and answer the little
phone call that he had unlit abuzz err
on the side before the ringleader saw me
that didn't work either
there was also a c3 company outside who
offered to help me fight the Marauders
on their way in but they would only
fight the Marauders on the outside and
not the inside I even went is so far to
go onto another playthrough to check the
back entrance of the tower to see if I
could skip right to there but I ended up
finding out
that is completely unacceptable
you cannot go to the top so sadly I had
no choice but to kill them so to answer
the question you cannot beat outer
worlds without killing anyone but we can
still see what the least amount of
number of people necessary to beat the
game is currently we're at seven after
talking to Hyrum he wanted us to get the
iron clasp in the MSI to stop
broadcasting this was simply doing a
couple quests for each group finding a
worker for the iron class and then
redoing the printing press the worker
wasn't too hard just a simple speech
check and you're in and the redoing the
printing press was a bit weird since it
took forever and there was a lot of raps
in there and this one big specific
rapped would not move for legit over
three minutes apparently he finally did
move and I was able to continue on with
the area and navigate without being
caught weirdly enough though if you do
activate the printing press button the
alarm sounds and actually all available
wraps that are in the building alive
actually completely run out of the
building in terror so very interesting
detail there once we are done we are now
onto Sanjar and Celia to talk with the
msi these quests involved getting a bolt
52 from a closet where someone snuck in
and then also uncover proof of corporate
presence and monarch I picked the udl
labs had this been some of the easiest
options that I had and snuck in there
since there was about three guards at
this lab two of which were glued to
whatever they were looking at so I only
had to pay attention to one of them
after that we returned to San Jar which
means no more broadcast from either
factions and we are now clear to
continue we returned the reliable' to
interrupt Sam and Ada getting a little
bit intimate I didn't really know what
to do at this point so I kind of backed
up after figuring out what was going on
and decided to not mention it to Ada
currently at this moment we are
absolutely breezing through this game
only about an hour and a half to two
hours into my recording for this and
right now with our phases being at level
14 thanks to the inspiration skill being
at level 60 we are now leveling stuff up
with a hundred and one and persuade and
intimidation and 66 in the like category
and this was shaping up to be a super
breezed out run i had to of course come
to a conclusion of which ending i wanted
to do i ended up choosing the phineas
ending to go through with it
now having entered Byzantium we needed
to visit Minister Clark the guard
wouldn't let us in so we needed to steal
his package and return back to minister
Clark but he didn't like me too much
Clark finally gave in and told me how to
get to the Chairman Rockwell's office
we weren't of course allowed in his
office so we had to bribe the guard to
let me through
going up the elevator we finally made it
to the Chairman's office and I've been
here many times on many playthroughs
doing many different things and I still
have no idea why that this door leads to
a busted-up wall then to his office I
still have no idea what this means
finally after getting the info we made
it to the lab but we immediately ran
through the open elevator and did one
full loop for the door to open perfectly
on time I had done this many times
before Brother guards had actually
talked to me through the elevator I'm
unsure how he even heard me or how that
even happened but either way we ignored
him and the sneaking actually in this
area wasn't too big of an issue a lot of
the scientists actually don't give a
[ __ ] that you're there it's just the
guards so just going around some of the
guards and patrols takes them a little
bit of maneuvering we were able to make
it to the lab you have to do the 22%
option because if you do the 100% option
then that kills people in the tank and
we're not allowed to do that
we returned to Phineas's chemicals and
hand and then jump the hope from here on
I was super confident with the run going
through the hope was really simple
because there's an ID cartridge in the
room right next door allowing you to not
be spotted we ended up meeting a guy
named Quincy and he was really mad and
annoyed at the fact that I was here but
I was more annoyed at the fact that I
had searched the internet for 30 minutes
trying to figure out who the [ __ ] his
voice actor is and I still can't figure
out who it is I'm about 90% certain that
he voices a an NCR guard or some [ __ ] in
New Vegas but I'm not sure but it keeps
clicking in my head and I can't figure
it out I need somebody's help in the
comments you've got about 5 seconds to
tell me what you're doing here before I
make you take a walk outside after
jumping the ship we find out that
Phineas was captured and we have we have
to travel back to his lab this is
actually a lot easier than I originally
intended
apparently there's only one guy that
walks back and forth while the other
three just sit and look at stuff this
was easy to slip by after grabbing the
key and figuring out what happened you
uh you go to Tartarus to finish the game
Tartarus was super easy all you have to
do is convince the guard to give you an
ID cartridge so you can blend in and
once you've done that it's super easy
you can just walk past all the guards
and it's
really hard to fail this part chairman
Rockwell eventually interrupts you but
you don't have to do anything to him you
can literally just end his speech as
fast as you want if you totally want to
once I got done with that I ended up
meeting Sophia and this is where the
ending happened after using charm and
intimidation 100 I had convinced her to
leave the colony completely and step
down from the board after that we took a
new entrance found Phineas rescued him
and kind of be out of worlds without
killing anyone
thanks to haram we failed the challenge
which is very sad and we ended this game
with these seven respectable kills that
we had to do because of Haram so just
because of that we ended up loading back
a previous save I checked in with Felix
and he wanted to give him his annual
vibe check he failed in all seriousness
note this run was actually really
entertaining I'm not going to show the
ending in this video but I will have a
link to an unlisted video that will show
you the ending credits for the section
that I beat with the Phineas ending and
then the board ending which I have to go
rerecord and do again because you can of
course also convince Phineas to step
down that has its own different ending
so if you do want to see the end credits
of what happens if you don't kill any
anybody throughout the game on the both
main endings for phineas and the board
then forego click the link in the
description it'll be an unlisted video
for you other than that I actually
genuinely enjoyed doing this run I
didn't think it was actually going to be
as fun as the killing everybody
challenge which was the past one but
this honestly had to be one of my
favorite videos I've made it's very
different and it was actually a lot
easier to complete than the killing
everyone part yeah let me know what you
guys think about this video in the
comments below as well as let me know
any other challenge runs that you guys
want me to do as well like I said the
endings will be in the description down
below if you guys want to check those
out they're actually really cool endings
and a lot of neat things happen that you
normally wouldn't know if you didn't do
this stuff so definitely go check that
out
hey guys take care like the VP do enjoy
subscribe if you're new take care enjoy
and peace out
[Music]